vor wenigen minuten hatte paul
ronzheimer unser mann vor ort dort die
gelegenheit mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky an einem geheimen
ort zu sprechen er wollte unter anderem
wissen wie groß ist seine angst von
putins killerkommandos getötet zu werden
wir herrn rahn in das interview
präsident es gibt berichte von der
wagner gruppe die sie töten wollen und
dass wladimir putin sie töten
und meine zweite frage was kann europa
tun was der deutsche kanzler um sie zu
unterstützen dass sie diesen krieg
gewinnen
ich bin auch ein mensch wie jeder mensch
wollen wir alle lieben und wenn ein
mensch keine angst um sein eigenes leben
oder das leben anderer menschen die in
den krieg geschickt werden hat ist das
kein normaler mensch und auch wie jeder
normale mensch habe auch ich angst um
mein leben um das leben einer verwandten
und was mein eigenes leben betrifft ich
als präsident dieses landes habe kein
recht angst zu haben meine seele
schmerzt auch und ich mache mir sorgen
um meine verwandten und wir haben angst
unser leben in den ort wo wir leben zu
verlieren ich habe angst mir
vorzustellen dass ich kein land mehr
habe und wenn man fragt wo kommst du her
und du sagst solches land gibt es nicht
mehr vor sowas habe ich angst ich habe
angst was wir unsere nächsten generation
überlassen und was die ganze welt
betrifft die welt soll wissen genauso
wie herr scholz beiden marken dass wir
schon mehrmals angesprochen haben dass
es uns sehr wichtig ist
sicherheitsgarantien zu haben das habe
ich von anfang an gesagt als ich
präsident geworden bin wenn ihr nicht
zeigt dass ihr eine starke union sei ob
es nato oder eu ist die ziele und werte
sind gleich sicherheit kultur und wenn
ihr eure eigenen werte und die union
nicht schützt die werden nicht mehr ex
ist ihr das alles passiert jetzt und das
habe ich schon vorher ehrlich über die
nato gesagt wenn ihr eure eigene union
eure länder der allianz nicht schützt
mit sanktionen mit harten antworten auf
bedrohungen
es wird sie nicht mehr geben
zum beispiel diese situation mit
weißrussland mit den flüchtlingen auf
der polnischen grenze was hat die
allianz gesagt muss man abwarten warten
auf was denn ich sage nicht dass man
einen krieg führen muss nein die stärke
jeder allianz ist jeden krieg zu
verhindern man muss so stark sein um am
verhandlungstisch alle punkte besprechen
zu können jedes land egal ob klein oder
groß sollten gleiche rechte haben das
ist der sinn einer allianz
als litauen nach kabeln für die grenze
bei uns in der ukraine nachgefragt hat
das war doch schwächer was für eine
allianz ist das über welche stärke reden
wir das war doch keine gleich
gerechtigkeit das gleiche passiert mit
der ukraine als wir über nord stream 2
gesprochen haben
ich habe mit allen staaten gesprochen
auch mit beiden ich habe ihn versucht zu
verdeutlichen dass die preise steigen
werden es wird kein markt mehr geben es
wird nur noch ein gas monopol geben nach
dem nordring 2 startet und die ukraine
wird damit ausgeschlossen sein der druck
auf die ukraine wird künstlich erhöht
auch jetzt mit dieser ganzen eskalation
rhetorik und was jetzt passiert
die verlangen dass wir unsere waffen nie
da liegen aufgeben zu kämpfen die
annexion unseres territoriums
akzeptieren was soll weiter passieren
politikerdynastie
und wir gehen direkt zur paul ronzheimer
der dieses interview vor wenigen minuten
geführt hatte live in kiew paul
beschreibt uns so ein bisschen die
atmosphäre dieses interviews an diesem
geheimen ort ja was kannst du uns
berichten was hinter den kulissen noch
passierte
sandra in dem fall war es vorher ein
geheimer ort dort wo das interview dann
stattgefunden hat da sieht man das ist
das präsidenten gebäude das bedeutet
aber nicht dass selensky dort jetzt
weiterhin ist das lief sehr interessant
ab auch etwas unheimlich fast kann man
sagen dass ich habe heute morgen eine
whatsapp nachricht bekommen bitte finden
sie sich dann und dann an diesen check
point ein es geht aber unter ihren
eigenen risiko wir können nicht für
ihren schutz versprechen und dann ging
es weiter mit einer gruppe einzelner
journalisten dann in dieses präsidenten
gebäude da war ich schon häufiger ich
habe dort wo schwenkow interview
zielinski interviewt aber immer in
friedenszeiten als ich da rein bin ich
hab's nicht mehr wiedererkannt das licht
war ausgeschaltet ich bin dann dadurch
habe überall sandsäcke gesehen in den
verschiedenen seiten unheimlich das muss
man sich mal vorstellen so als würde man
so im interview so olaf scholz gehen und
alle lichter sind ausgeschaltet und man
läuft durch einen raum und fliegt fast
auf die nase weil man über die treppen
läuft also eine völlig absurde situation
auch dann sind wir dort in diesem
presseraum gegangen der sei wiederum
normal aus andere allerdings wurde er
natürlich geschützt von
schwerbewaffneten ukrainischen soldaten
sehen wir gerade und da gab es sozusagen
bei den bei den soldaten dann kamen sie
lenski dazu hat sich dann stuhl genommen
und ist ja hat sich dorthin gesetzt und
hat mir kurz werden kurz die hand
geschüttelt weil wir uns kennen und dann
hat er losgelegt sehr entspannt
tatsächlich trotz dieses wahnsinnigen
druck
er ist ja auch direkt ein ziel paul wie
weit er überhaupt geschützt wir sehen
hier die bewaffneten männer an seiner
seite wenn wir das bild sehen noch mal
wie du mit ihm gesprochen hast wird er
ständig an einen anderen ort gebracht um
eben nicht getroffen werden zu können
nicht ermordet werden zu können
er wechselt sehr häufig den ort an dem
man sich auffällt da wird natürlich auch
nichts darüber preisgegeben wie oft das
passiert wie regelmäßig das passiert
dass er tatsächlich dort im denn gebäude
ist findet
denke ich mal nicht mehr den ganzen tag
statt es war tatsächlich auch so
normalerweise bei solchen
zusammentreffen wäre man als tv team
möglicherweise live drauf gegangen das
hätten wir eine live kamera aufgebaut
aber da haben sie längst mitarbeiter
gesagt bitte erst nach dem gespräch
veröffentlichen wenn das gespräch zu
ende ist also sinn denn ski sich wieder
aus diesem gebäude entfernt hat auch das
zeigt ja wie nervös die lage ist denn
natürlich du sprichst es an die lenski
ist der feind nummer eins und ihn möchte
man töten paul interpretiert und
analysiert doch bitte noch mal für uns
dieses zeichen was er damit auch setzt
er sammelt die journalisten seines
vertrauens versammelt sie im
regierungsgebäude streng geheim alles
aber er gibt eine pressekonferenz in
diesen stunden in diesen minuten was ist
das für ein signal
ja das ist ein absolutes zeichen der
entschlossenheit der geschlossenheit das
war noch nicht alles journalisten seines
vertrauens da war jetzt dabei zum
beispiel mbc war dabei fox news also die
großen us sender die er natürlich auch
erreichen muss die amerikanische
bevölkerung die usa ist sehr sehr
wichtig dafür dass zum beispiel weitere
waffenlieferungen kommen dass es darum
geht die ukraine weiter zu unterstützen
aber sander ich fand interessant die
situation als er reinkam und er hat sich
da den stuhl genommen natürlich auch
alles show er weiß was er dort machen
muss und hat sich so bis auf einen meter
fast an die journalisten herr angesetzt
und wirkte völlig entspannt will ich
nicht sagen aber
im vergleich zu dem wie wladimir putin
seine pressekonferenzen hält einfach
eine 180 grad wende auch da dieser
unterschied wir erinnern uns an den
langen tisch von wladimir putin und im
vergleich dazu wie lenski der sich den
stuhl selber mitnimmt und direkt vor die
journalisten hockt sicherlich auch alles
symbolik alles zeichen seelands die
macht nicht zufällig der war lange im tv
geschäft und weiß genau wie er sich
selbst inszenieren will das muss man
immer wissen wenn man solche bilder
sieht und dennoch ist das ja ein signal
ist dass das signal ich bin anders ich
bin ein offener präsident ich stelle
mich der presse ich beantworte alle
fragen und ja das zeigt schon wie
kämpferischer ist er wirkte natürlich
bühne hat uns erzählt dass er nur drei
stunden schläft am tag aber ansonsten
hat er klare nachrichten gesandt hat
weiter um unterstützung gebeten hat
gesagt das sieht man mir dass sie nicht
aufgeben werden er hat außerdem davon
gesprochen dass er wenn er nicht
präsident wäre er auch teil der zivilen
verteidigung wäre also er beruft hat
noch mal aufgerufen dazu dass sich die
menschen so zu sagen ja zu ihm bekennen
zu der territorialverteidigung auch
bekennen paul ronzheimer vielen dank du
stehst du vor einem dunklen kirche
wieder einmal wieder eine dunkle nacht
in dieser zweiten woche des krieges
wieder eine nacht von der er nicht wisse
was auf euch zukommt danke für deine
informationen pause